in bolton the vaccination rate has
quadrupled in a week as
efforts are stepped up to contain the
indian variant
the highly infectious version of the
virus is already the dominant strain in
the area
if it spreads it puts at risk our summer
of freedom
and in the commons the health secretary
urged people to have the jab
just look at what's happening in bolton
hospital
where the majority of people in hospital
with coronavirus
were eligible for the job but have
chosen
not yet to have the jab and have ended
up in hospital
some of them in intensive care vaccines
save lives
indoor mixing is the biggest step in the
lifting of lockdown so far
the virus spreads between 10 and 100
times more easily indoors than out
depending on the activity there is a
danger of complacency and i think we do
need to remind people that we're not out
of the woods yet and we know that when
we pull the plug as it were at some
point
cases start to go up again we're in a
different situation now because we have
the vaccine
but we haven't got to the levels of herd
immunity that we need yet
at the forge inn in glenfield the
landlord is doing all he can to let the
clean air in
and keep customers safe we've spaced our
tables out we've got windows open we're
very blessed here that the property
existing
was really open spaces we've got high
ceilings
um you know and there's plenty of way to
plenty of places for people to move
around without
brushing past them once it was thought
the virus was transmitted on surfaces
now scientists know it lingers in the
air for anywhere from three to sixteen
hours according to lab studies
and that is the main route of
transmission if i did have covid19 i'd
be breathing out around a thousand
copies of the virus
every five seconds within an hour of
sitting here i might have filled the
average size
pub with around 2 000 virus particles in
every cubic meter of air
but open a window and the air would be
cleared
three times an hour open a window on the
other side
and the cross breeze would clear it much
faster reducing the risk for anybody
inside
this hot spot this scientist has studied
the airborne spread of the virus
he says just because we can mix indoors
doesn't mean we should
if i see that windows are closed it's
really crowded lots of people
and there's no ventilation vents in the
ceiling there's a plywood in the feeling
i'll probably say
you know what why don't we go somewhere
else or just stay outside
hospital admissions and deaths are now
as low as they were last summer
but easing lock down with an infectious
variant on the loose
makes the future far from certain
thomas more sky news in leicester